seattle's political leadership voted to
defund the police last year what are
they doing with all the money
well they put some of it into a new
initiative to degrade and destroy their
own
people the city is now funding a
homeless shelter that's passing out
heroin pipes and distributing so-called
booty bumping kits so that junkies can
inject drugs rectally for real
seattle's human services department says
the program quote reflects the varying
needs of those experiencing homelessness
in seattle jason rantz is seattle radio
host he's been documenting the
destruction of his city he joins us
tonight
jason thanks so much for coming on if if
you really hated the people you were in
charge of it seems to me you do things
like this
yeah i mean when you teach addicts who
are already the hardest to get off the
street
a more efficient way to get high in a
way that
lasts longer when you're doing it with
the so-called booty bumping kits
all you're doing is making it that much
easier for them to stay addicted
we have an organization in the downtown
emergency services center
that should be helping these people and
they say this is all part of a harm
reduction model
that it's about being where the addict
is and making sure that
since they're going to engage in this
behavior anyway at least they're doing
it
safer but at the end of the day the
results speak for themselves and
homelessness
and addiction is getting worse in
seattle and king county we just had a
stunning increase and that's in the
language of the very people doing the
study
of an increase in fentanyl overdoses
meth overdoses going through the roof
every step of the way we're seeing the
results worsening not getting better so
maybe harm reduction is literally doing
the opposite
well maybe it's intentional i mean if
you did this to your kids people would
say well you obviously hate your kids
you're making it easier for them to do
heroin
a lot of people die i mean that that
degrades them it will kill them
ultimately why isn't it very clear to us
they wouldn't do this to a population
they loved or cared about
well because we've sort of leaped into
this pc culture they'll say that they
don't want to stigmatize
anybody who is experiencing this and you
and i have had this conversation
before i don't want to stigmatize people
i don't want to shame people who are
sick and they need help
but i do want to stigmatize the act of
shooting up or smoking
heroin we should not be glorifying it we
should not be
making it sound like it's exciting to
give another
aspect of drug addiction a try we should
be making sure that everybody
understands
that this is unacceptable it's not okay
to do this in a park
it's not okay to do this in an alleyway
and it's certainly not okay to do it in
a city-backed
center for homeless especially not okay
to do with city funds
the funny thing is if they were passing
out marlboros to the homeless people
would freak out those are bad for you
but not heroin it's totally it's a
really diseased mind uh i would say
responsible for this
jason it's great to see you thank you
thanks tucker